what's going on guys today we're going
to analyze how shinzo's presence changed
everything
during the first battle between class 1a
and class 1b just by him being there
characters from class 1b had to alter
their behavior during the fight
and this had a knock-on effect
throughout the entire episode in this
video i'll be breaking down the multiple
way since i had an impact
and why the persona cores are his
greatest weapon before we begin please
do drop a like and hit that sub button
if you haven't already
as we are tantalizingly close to 300k
subscribers
okay so for those of you who haven't
started my here academia season 5
classes 1a and 1b are currently involved
in a joint trading battle
which is a way of testing how their
quirks and intelligence has evolved
students from each class will put into
random teams and in total there will be
five separate matches by the time this
thing is over
the first match put these four students
from class 1a against these four from
class 1b
plus a special guest hitoshi shinzo
first appeared around the sports
festival and from the first moment he
was introduced it was pretty clear
that he wanted to join the hero course
currently he's doing general studies in
class 1c
in his hopes of transferring to the hero
course now rests on how well he does in
this joint training exercise
the aim of the game is to capture four
people from the opposing team
and lock them up inside your own team's
prison cell but you can also win if the
20 minute timer runs out
and your team has more people left in
the game now in order to explain how
hitoshi affected the entire match
we first need to understand his power
the brainwashing quirk lets him control
people who respond to him
which we previously saw him doing the
sports festival to ogero deku and
several others
but in deku's case it was especially
weird because obviously they activated
the vestiges
as kaminari implied the problem with
this power is that once an enemy knows
about it
they can just make the conscious
decision not to reply to him without
receiving a response to something he
said
shinzo can't bring with someone hence
why he has this brand new support item
the persona cause can modify the sound
of his voice to mimic someone else
so when he uses them he doesn't sound
like himself this is a priceless ability
because he can pretend to be another
person and obviously when used right
people will unknowingly respond to him
this is what changed the
entire dynamic of the fight since it
eventually made class 1 be too afraid to
properly communicate
in the beginning shishida and subaraba
went into full attack mode
briefly taking down kirishima froppy and
koda in one go
their strategy was clever because they
knew class when they would be distracted
by what ibarra was doing
since she is canonically the strongest
1b student all class 1 b knew about
hitoshi
was that he could brainwash people if
they responded and that a good hit could
break someone out of it
they had no idea what the persona chords
could do which gave himself an opening
to mimic subaraba's voice
and brainwashed the beast this moment
from hitoshi was really important for
two reasons
number one it temporarily stopped the
main attacking force of class 1b
leading to a series of events where
froppy captured subaraba with her tongue
hatchishida not been brainwashed he
would have continued to wreck class 1a
but this moment of pause gave kaminari
the chance to charge himself with
electricity
that meant that when shishida did break
out and finally attack he was
electrocuted in the process
and of course froppy and kirishima had
more time to recover from the previous
assault
the second reason why this was important
was that one bee now became aware of the
persona chords with shishida being the
most affected
his fear of being brainwashed is
ultimately what caused bombie to lose
evidenced by the climax of the battle
because his beast quirk gives him a
heightened sense of smell
he always knew where class when he was
located and his teammates relied on him
for that information
even though the borough was brainwashed
shishida still could have told rin where
the remaining enemies were hiding but
instead he kept his mouth shut
and vaguely pointed to the rights this
was seriously unhelpful
as it distracted rin for a split second
and allowed froppy to grab it barra
before she could be woken up
the reason he didn't talk out loud was
because he was so wary of being
brainwashed he refused to verbally
communicate until shinzo was taken out
as a result rin wasted more time trying
to get him to talk rather than trying to
locate froppy himself
and this gave froppy the advantage
purely due to his presence
hitoshi severed the lines of
communication between shishida and the
rest of class 1b
and because they were so reliant on him
this meant they were doomed to fail as
deku noted
the potential heroical student still has
much to improve on when it comes to
combat
but we already knew that wasn't his
strength instead woody did enable the
rest of the team floppy in particular
to use the physical size of their quirks
to win the binding club you had is the
same as izawa
and vigilante's readers will know it
takes a long time to master this thing
this episode made clear that shinzo
knows when to use it but his body isn't
strong or fast enough to make it truly
useful just yet
if he joins the hero course then his
physical strength will improve
exponentially
mainly down to the fact he'll be
fighting terrorists every other week
perhaps the most visually pleasing part
about seeing all this animated is the
epic way the persona calls move when
they're mimicking someone's voice
for me this is just one of those things
that can't be conveyed that well on
paper
so yeah it looks way better in animated
form anyway shinzo is scheduled to take
part in the last match of the joint
training
where that time he'll be on class 1b
side instead of class 1a
this means the rematch of deku is going
to happen and yeah we will see how that
goes
let me know down below what you guys
thought of the episode and don't forget
to hit that sub button if you like the
video
until the next one peace out